- If you asked me, what scares me more,
having way too much, or
having way too little?
It's having way too much.
(intense music)
- [Interviewer] Who
turned you into this guy?
Did something turn you--
- America, and my mother.
You know, I was born in the Soviet Union,
I didn't come up with much.
So, adversity, America,
my mom, and my dad,
because when I was 14, and started working
at my dads liquor store
for two bucks an hour,
I was so full of shit.
And, he sucked it out of me over 10 years,
'cause he hates lying and bullshit.
And so, he scared me.
I scared to embellish, let alone lie.
I don't get upset when people are like,
"Yo, this guy's full of shit".
Because I'm like, "I understand,
I actually had that in me."
But, my dad systematically took it out.
And, I think it comes
from lack of entitlement.
- Is entitlement a disease?
- 100.
I'm scared shit-less of
properly raising my children
'cause they're gonna have so much.
Listen, straight up,
and I know the audience,
I know the culture, I get it.
But, straight up, if you
asked me, what scares me more,
having way to much, or
having way too little?
It's having way too much.
- [Interviewer] Way too much?
- 100%
Because that person is
suicidal and depressed.
- [Interviewer] But,
doesn't that fall in line
with abundance?
- Yeah, but people can't,
you can't see happiness.
There's so many people I know
that make $40,000 a year,
and love life.
And, so many people I know that
have 40 million in the bank,
and hate life.
And, everybody's saying like,
"cool, I'll take my chances,
I'll be 40 million."
I get it, but guess what?
That's what the 40 million
persons saying, too.
Like, "damn, I wish I wasn't
born with this trust fund."
People aren't listening.
The reason I talk about
materialistic things,
it is the bandaid and the
make-up of unhappiness for 95%.
They're trying to impress
people they don't even like.
You've seen a bunch of
people come through here.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Right?
People have come through
here when they were
just starting their careers,
- [Interviewer] Sure.
Two years later, they
popped, they came in here,
you're about to figure
out exactly who they are.
Were they the same person they
walked in here 19 months ago?
- [Interviewer] Yes, yes.
- Some do, and they
leave, and you're like,
"Yo, thank god, that's good people."
- [Interviewer] Yup.
- And, sometimes people come
in here and they forgot.
- Have you learned from Hip Hop?
Have you learned anything
from sitting down with Nipsey?
- Yeah but, what I learned
from Hip Hop, or the culture,
happened a long, long time ago.
It happened in Edison, New Jersey.
But, it really, really happened
in Newton, Massachusetts.
I went to Mount Ida
College from '94 to '98,
it was, y'know, 96%
minorities, it was 95% of them
on financial aid.
I learned a lot because I was deep in it.
I didn't visit my friend
in the hood for a day.
For four years, I lived deep in it.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- And, that's when I got a sense of it.
And, what it taught me
that half decade, was,
"Oh, this is exactly what I'm about."
- Is there anybody in Hip
Hop that's not utilizing
this opportunity that they have?
- All of 'em!
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Nobody's squeezing it hard enough.
- [Interviewer] What are they not doing?
- They don't realize how
valuable the attention is,
right now, on social media.
They're sitting on their music.
Put your music out!
The internet is where
peoples attention is.
You got music?
Post it on instagram right now.
You have nine followers?
Start it.
Everybody thinks you
need a million followers.
What if your one follower is you.
It's not about how many, it's
who, and what can they do?
If you got Sound Cloud,
and Spotify, and Instagram,
and YouTube?
Guys, Tee Grizzley comes
out of fucking jail after 5,
4 and a half years.
From being locked up for a half decade,
to putting out one
fucking video and a song,
if you've got talent,
this is about talent,
- [Interviewer] Sure.
- And all of a sudden, 72 hours later,
21 Savage is DM-ing you.
So, if you've got flames,
and you've got bars,
and your fucking so great, put it out.
But, what's happening
is, people are insecure.
- [Interviewer] Of course.
- People are overthinking shit.
People are artists,
trying to make it perfect.
- [Interviewer] Sure.
- Its ego.
- But also too, I think
sometimes it can be that,
the internet and social
media can be a curse
because they just come at you,
and they're attacking you daily.
- Yeah, but when you can hear them.
But, when you can hear
them, it doesn't matter.
When you get to that place
when you can't hear them?
Then, you start making content.
Then, you start living your life for real.
It's just like high school.
Remember in the beginning
of the high school,
you were worried about
everybody's opinion?
But then, kinda, by senior
year, you got your click,
- [Interviewer] Yeah, you're good.
- You didn't give a fuck.
- I'm just trying to get
everybody in real life
to get to the place they
were in high school,
the last month of high school.
It comes back to self awareness, my guy.
There is no one path,
the only path is like,
"Do you know yourself?"
And, more importantly, that
voice inside your own head?
A lot of times, people don't understand,
that that was put in your head.
A lot of people, when I'm like,
"Don't listen to anybody but yourself."
I'll get that DM.
They'll be like, "Yo, I
love that, my problem is,
I'm telling myself I suck."
And then, I have to DM
them like, "Yo, you didn't.
Like, that isn't you.
That's your mom or dad
that put that in your head.
And, now you believe it and
you think it's your own voice."
Nobody starts off thinking they suck.
Here's the problem, and
I'm not trying to be mean,
I'm trying to make you happy and win,
most of the people listening right now
don't have the talent.
- [Interviewer] And that's
the truth, and that's okay.
- And, that is okay.
- [Interviewer] It's okay.
- By the way, some of the
cats in this room probably,
when you guys were seven,
eight, nine, ten, eleven,
might have thought you wanted
to be the artist, but--
- I wanted to be a
singer, but I can't sing.
- They thought, "I wanna
rap, I wanted to sing,
I wanted to dance."
- Right? Right?
And, what I would say is, "kudos to you."
To be like, you understood
that you weren't gonna be,
y'know, Queen Latifah,
so you had to fucking--
- [Interviewer] Brutally
honest with yourself.
- That's it.
You know what I love?
I love perspective.
If you're listening to this right now,
it means you have the ability
to listen to this right now.
Which means, you live in America,
it means you have some sort
of device that allows you
to listen to this.
I just don't think people
understand how lucky they have it.
No matter how shitty
they think they have it.
- [Interviewer] Gary, I read
somewhere that millennials
don't want to be told what to do,
but they all need to be told what to do.
- Listen, I'm so tired of old
people judging millennials
when they're the ones who
fucking raised these millennials.
Why won't we talk about the parents
that raised the millennials--
- [Interviewer] Starts
at home, doesn't it?
- That created the entitlement,
who didn't want their kids ever crying,
who wanted their kids to be in games
where eighth place trophies happen.
And then, #2, like, here's my thing,
it doesn't matter what that report says.
I know a ton of millennials
that bleed out of their eyes
19 hours a day, and want it.
It's funny, we've gotten
real politically correct
about not being prejudiced
about skin color,
or male, or female, right?
But, we're shitting on
millennials as a whole,
and I think it's totally unacceptable.
And, I want to remind
everybody, just because you put
"entrepreneur" in your Instagram title...
(laughter)
- Right?
And, you went and printed eight T-shirts
that came up with some word
that is now your brand,
doesn't mean you're a
successful entrepreneur.
I could put "basketball
player" in my fucking bio,
I play ball.
Guess what?
I don't get paid.
- [Interviewer] (laughing)
Right, right, right.
- There's a big difference
between being an entrepreneur,
and being a successful entrepreneur.
I believe in optimism, right?
But, if you don't back your
optimism, or manifestation
with fucking work and smarts?
Like, nobody you know,
nobody you know ever made it
without putting in the work.
From 15 to 30, I didn't
go anyway on the weekends,
no where.
Who did that?
Who worked 18 hours a day, for
fucking 15 years like I did?
Who left college on Friday afternoon
to take a bullshit Amtrak
down, and not even the Acela,
stop in every which way on the East Coast,
and then get into Jersey,
Wood Bridge train station,
and then drive to the liquor
store, work two hours,
then go home, sleep for six,
and then work all day
Sunday, and then wake up,
all day Saturday, for 13
hours in that liquor store,
then wake-up Sunday, right?
And, go back to Boston,
to go back to school.
So, don't "oh, Gary"
me, you don't know me.
- [Interviewer] Sure.
- I fucking worked
every minute of my life.
- How do you find your balance?
From work, and life, I guess?
- I love them both so much.
Y'know, like, I love 'em both so much.
I do what I need to do.
So, I think people are just
letting other peoples opinions,
so like, work-life balance, real easy.
I do what I want.
And, as long as the five to nine people
I give a fuck abut the most are
cool with it, then I'm good.
I'm not a motivational speaker
that wants you to pay me
$5,000 to be your coach.
I don't want your money,
I don't want anything.
- [Interviewer] Shots fired?
- Super shots fired.
(imitation shooting noises)
When people say they
want to change your life,
but real quick, give me $6,000 to do it?
You're not changing shit.
I'm chasing admiration, my guy.
- [Interviewer] That's right.
- You know what admiration feels like?
Like, if anybody's got it out there,
if you have it from one
person, your little niece,
y'know like,
- [Interviewer] It's amazing.
- Admiration, like, do
you know what I felt like,
coming in here today?
- [Interviewer] So good.
- Taking picture with
her in the front, like,
that's nice.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, man.
- I knew how to make money,
I know how to make money.
I don't need the people
watching me on the 'Gram
or YouTube, or my podcast
to give me their money.
I've always known how to do that.
I want your fucking admiration.
- My guy, Gary Vee, you're my guy, my guy.
- I appreciate it, my guy.
You're my guy too, my guy.
- My guy, you are my guy, my guy.
- Thank you, my man.
Thank you so much for having me.
- I'm serious, my guy.
- [Gary] I appreciate it.
- You are my guy, my guy.
- I appreciate that.
(intense slow music)